case how are we this morning are you
doing ok I want to know the difference
in morale now at three and one as
opposed to when you came into the
building at Owen one uh well you could
say you could say it's a lot different
and anytime you win went out game in
this league it's a big deal that won
three in a row is is obviously pretty
tough especially when it's two on the
road so we're we're all pretty excited
but you know we got a new challenge
ahead of us got the bills coming in and
you know they they've got things going
through as well so they've won two in a
row we've got some we've got some work
to do what's uh what did you think was
going to be the reaction to the Rams in
Los Angeles and what has been the
reaction you know I really had no idea
you know I think I'd only been here one
other time so I don't haven't really
experienced the LA lifestyle you could
say but I don't know I heard different
people say different things one one
rider said hey we didn't really invite
you here Rams but you better entertainer
if I walked around with you in Hollywood
is anybody recognizing you
there's a pretty good chance no now I
haven't walked around much in Hollywood
I couldn't speak for experience what if
you're wearing your full uniform you
know there's I would say just the amount
of people dressed up there they might
just think you know part of the crowd I
guess yeah I didn't know how guys were
gonna react you go from st. Louis in
that city to Los Angeles I mean those
are contrasting cities in Styles as well
so I didn't know as what's been the
toughest thing to get used to aside from
the traffic yeah it's tragic for sure
you know aside from that um the travel
we've been traveling quite a bit just
just to just to get on a plane to go to
Arizona um you know we're driving into
LAX
and you know being up here where we are
you know close to Cal Lutheran in
Thousand Oaks it's it's a trip in itself
just to get to the airport but you know
the family's coming in and traveling in
I would say just just the travel I mean
it's the the west coast is a long ways
away from everything else it seems like
he's a Case Keenum of the LA Rams
joining us by the way you're Houston
Cougars doing well they're doing all
right coach Sherman's got him going
are you nervous you're gonna lose coach
Herman I mean you're always nervous when
you got a coach like that but let's get
the guys going really well I think I
think he's got some really good things
going in his contract for you know if we
wind up in a bigger [ __ ] in a bigger
conference and you know just just the
way he's got those boys thinking is the
culture has changed they expect to win
and they're playing hard and it's been
fun to watch so you know coach Kerman
hummons a really really really good dude
he's reached out to a lot of the former
players too so we're all really excited
about him and hope hope he stays there a
long time well we had a backup
quarterback Sean Mannion on and he says
that he watches our show in the
quarterback meeting room is that true
yeah I'm a big fan we all are
I know I noticed you guys caught him
wearing is wearing a hundred they're on
hard not flinch ball t-shirt yes do you
have some t-shirt we did send him a
whole bundle of tea I don't know if he's
shared he doesn't strike me as the one
I'll make sure that yeah Jared needs a
little pick-me-up
so if we can get some t-shirts there to
help that get that guy do do okay there
all right helping around there up here
yeah we'll do that and and I would think
at 3 and 1 and a home game against the
bills you might get some of the
Hollywood celebrities is anybody been on
the sidelines so far you know the first
game we had yes you it seemed like you'd
look up at the screen and there'd be
somebody up there
I think LeBron was on the sidelines I
mean the Chili Peppers played before the
game which was I mean is awesome James
Gordon danced with the cheerleaders or
something he's like The Late Late yeah
Late Late Show guy Cee Lo Green sang the
national anthem so I'm sure there was
other people there but I was trying to
concentrate a little bit hard with all
the people walking around I was trying
to you know what I'm thinking can I send
you a t-shirt of McLovin McLovin broke
his glasses on the show when he was
spinning the ball he was gonna play
against the Harlem Globetrotters so then
we made a t-shirt of a pair of broken
glasses if we send you a t-shirt after
your next win is that asking too much to
maybe show up at the press conference
with that t-shirt on you can wear a
sport jacket on top of it yeah you can
it does it go yeah it's sport coat
doesn't go well with the with it casual
casual and classy yeah you know I think
I think it only fitting man just just
with all those drills that mclovin and I
ran in the offseason you know just show
me show me how to dodge defenders and
you know really really keep my eyes down
field when I'm when I'm spinning around
in the backfield
are you crediting McLovin for helping
the Rams jump out to a three-in-one
start you know I wouldn't I wouldn't
give him all the credit but you know
there's a part but you know I think he
played in and getting this going for
sure yes McLovin I mean to be fair it
was it was case and me it was us it
wasn't all you know I don't want all the
credit I want to share with my teammates
well there you go okay so McLovin is not
taking all the credit well that's good I
think anybody that's my third favorite
Sports Illustrated rider would would
would do that for sure okay well then
that's Tom he's in the top three so
who's who's one in to opt King Peter
King is yeah you gotta go there yeah and
I met I met I went toward the Sports
Illustrated offices a couple years ago
and I met somebody I forgot I forgot his
name but he's second
the guy's name you don't know his second
and McLovin his third on that list did
your wife like being on Hard Knocks
being featured you know first but you
know the producers did a really good job
of showing her and you know of letting
her kind of do her thing so when they
asked her to start calling plays they
had heard we did that before yeah we
thought that was kind of interesting but
it wound up pretty cool I mean we we got
some good reaction from it a lot of
people enjoyed it and they pretty much
think my wife's a bad a well Congrats
three-in-one start we'll get a shipment
of t-shirts out there for you and I'm
glad that mclovin maybe McLovin can move
up to number two on your Sports
Illustrated writers list case we'll see
we'll see the long all right Congrats so
far thanks for joining us thanks guys
all right that's case keenum Rams
quarterback the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience